[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la une de ça vous regarde ce soir un
invité exceptionnel ancien premier
ministre ancien candidat à la
présidentielle il a été maire de
bordeaux pendant plus de vingt ans il
est aujourd'hui membre du conseil
constitutionnel et il prend la plume
pour nous raconter son chirac il était
aux premières loges de la cérémonie
d'hommage qui était rendu à l'ancien
chef de l'état ce matin à l'assemblée
alain juppé est avec nous ce soir nous
parlons aussi des différentes formes
d'engagement en politique et s'il
suffrage universel n'était plus
suffisant un livre traite de ce sujet en
cette rentrée il est signée alice
zeniter jeune et talentueuse romancière
elle dialoguera elle notamment avec le
ministre en charge des relations avec le
parlement
marc fesneau sans oublier bien sûr la
chronique de thomas des prix ce soir
ces jeunes et heureux papa qui pourront
pouponner plus longtemps voilà mon
programme mais tout de suite place à
notre grand témoin
[Musique]
bienvenue sur ce plateau alain juppé
bonsoir et merci infiniment d'avoir
accepté notre invitation il ya un an
presque jour pour jour disparaissait et
jacques chirac votre mentor en politique
celui qui vous a ouvert tant de portes
c'est lui qui vous a tant appris voudra
compter dans ce très beau témoignage en
forme de confession en forme de lettre à
jacques chirac m'ont chirac
une amitié singulière aux éditions
taillandier on va y revenir longuement
40 ans de vie politique c'est un peu un
autoportrait aussi en creux parle de moi
aussi mais d'abord revenons sur cette
cérémonie qui avait lieu ce matin à
laquelle vous avez assisté à l'assemblée
nationale toute la chiraquie comme on
disait à l'époque était là on peut citer
le cercle intime bien sûr claude chirac
frédéric salat baroux
mais aussi françois baroin jean louis
debré christian jacob qu'est ce que ça
fait de retrouver ces gens là dans cette
maison là c'était un très bon moment et
j'ai un jour de dire que je retrouvais
beaucoup d'amis comme je ne siège plus à
l'assemblée nationale depuis quelques
années j'avais perdu un petit peu le
contact et ça a été pour moi un grand
plaisir de les retrouver mais c'était la
chiraquie et un peu plus que la chaire
équipe est ce que vous l'avez tous les
bancs de l'assemblée nationale était
garnie entre guillemets par de nombreux
parlements bellevarde en un instant il
ya eu un moment d'unité autour du
discours du président ferrand que fait
un très beau discours dans lequel il a
rappelé les étapes de la carrière de
jacques chirac mais dans lequel surtout
il a montré qu'il avait bien senti la
personnalité profonde de jacques chirac
j'ai retenu deux mots qui me passent
bien résumé finalement sa philosophie
politique c'était un républicain très
attaché aux valeurs républicaines et
donc très déterminé à ne jamais se
compromettre avec la droite extrême et
c'était aussi un humaniste très attentif
également à ceux qui avaient le plus
besoin d'attention alors on va en parler
de jacques chirac ce lien charnel avec
les français qu'il avait pour reprendre
la formule de richard ferrand le
président de l'assemblée nationale
retour en images sur cette matinée
exceptionnelle
une plaque a été dévoilée à l'endroit
même où jacques chirac à siéger dans
l'hémicycle
garder c'est un sujet dame et à dia si
le moment solennel de la journée côte à
côte
le président de l'assemblée nationale et
claude chirac la fille de l'ancien chef
de l'état
ensemble ils dévoilent la plaque en
l'honneur de jacques chirac
applaudissements nourris il y a les
chiraquiens de la première heure alain
juppé jean louis debré l'ancien premier
ministre edouard philippe
mais aussi des personnalités de gauche
jean luc mélenchon anne hidalgo ou
l'ancien président de l'assemblée claude
bartolone la plaque de cuivre la 65e de
l'hémicycle est apposée au dessus du
siège 99 le siège même qu'occupait
jacques chirac à l'assemblée lorsqu'il
était député de corrèze
dans son discours le président de
l'assemblée saluent à chirac qui a su
incarner l'essentiel de la france à la
façon des trois mousquetaires comme
porte aus
il aimait la simplicité la cordialité
comme atos plus complexes tourmente et
qu'il s'efforçait de paraître il savait
conserver sa part de secret comme aramis
séducteur et séduisant fin tacticien
réunissent en lui les qualités des trois
mousquetaires jacques chirac s'inspira
finalement librement de leur devise en
proclamant la france pour tous et tous
pour la france
jacques chirac a été député de la
corrèze pendant plus de 16 ans deux fois
président deux fois premier ministre
ceux qui l'ont côtoyé met en avant la
profonde humanité du personnage un
humanisme l'humanité une ouverture sur
les autres en respect un profond et
public est un passionné de la france
voilà on est heureux aussi l'accompagner
dans les mémoires j'ai connu des
mouvements personnel extrêmement
chaleureux courageux c'est quelqu'un qui
est au fond savait se faire aimer
et c'est ce qu'on entend et ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui j'ai eu la chance de le
connaître de le rencontrer évidemment
parce qu'il avait gardé cet attachement
à paris
et d'être toujours extrêmement
chaleureux je pense qu'il incarne
quelque chose qui pour les politiques
doit être aussi une priorité
c'est cette empathie et ce contact ce
goût du contact goût des autres la
cérémonie c'est aussi l'occasion de
retrouvailles pas si fréquente que cela
finalement une bonne partie du personnel
politique de droite mais aussi de gauche
rassemblée dépassant les clivages
partisans pour un hommage singulier un
nom après la mort de l'ancien chef de
l'état
voilà une plaque dans l'hémicycle plaque
à la place 99 pour être précise alain
juppé en bonne compagnie parce que pas
très loin et michel debré est un peu
plus loin et georges pompidou son mentor
il est bien là où il est avec cette
plaque savez que c'est georges pompidou
qui va donner toutes ses chances en lui
donnant un poste ministériel quelques
jours à peine avaient ils été élu député
de la corrèze et il y avait entre
pompidou et chirac un peu la même
relation entre chirac et moi c'était une
relation qui n'était pas intimes nous
n'appartenions pas au cercle de famille
rapprochée mais qui était une réaction
d'estimé réciproque et de confiance
surtout une confiance ne s'est jamais
démentie et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai intitulé mon livre une
amitié singulière parce que cette
confiance maintenue pendant 40 ans c'est
pas si fréquent que ça en politique une
loyauté une confiance
vous continuez à vous voyez ça peut
surprendre parce que en politique le
tutoiement est tellement fréquent il ya
une pudeur ya même une distance sont
revendiquées dans ce lien si singulier
vous décrire une pudeur une distance
peut-être mais ça s'explique par les
circonstances dans lesquelles j'ai connu
jacques chirac je l' ai connu pour la
première fois en 1976 il était premier
ministre et j'étais jeune fonctionnaire
entrant à son cabinet donc un jeune
fonctionnaire le tutoie pas le premier
ministre quand il ne le connaît pas et
on a gardé cette habitude au fil des
années je crois qu'il ne faut pas
s'accrocher trop de choses
superficielles parfois des tutoiements
politiques sont un peu superficiel et ne
signifie pas toujours un message gardez
vous voit mans qui en dit plus long sur
le lien de proximité on parle un petit
peu de
de jacques chirac parlementaire
franchement entre nous c'était pas
franchement son truc qu'on a on a
retrouvé une archive une archive des
années 80 contre les années mitterrand
donc jacques chirac est alors député de
corrèze classique chef de l'opposition
regard des vacances a pris la mauvaise
direction
si nous sommes aujourd'hui sur la pente
du déclin
ce sont les choix que vous avez fait
depuis le 10 mai 81 qui en portent la
responsabilité
ne cherchez donc pas avant vous ou alors
de vous les causes de l'échec fait enfin
preuve d'un peu d'humilité et de
lucidité
regardez en roumaine depuis plus d'un an
vous avez tous les pouvoirs cessez donc
de battre notre coulpe sur la poitrine
d'autrui la vôtre vraiment n'est-elle
pas assez large
l incident de 1982 il a été élu une fois
député jacques chirac le terrain ça
c'est sûr il y était tout le temps
la corrèze on le sait mais franchement
d'hémicycle c'était s'était pas sa
passion vous vous dites d'ailleurs que
vous avez ça on partage dans votre livre
j'ai un peu le même comportement que lui
j'étais parlementaire assez longtemps
mais la plupart du temps j'étais au
gouvernement ou chefs de partis et le
chef du parti il est en général exonérés
des longues séances à l'assemblée
nationale là c'est le chirac des années
80 chirac combatif chef de partie face
aux gouvernements miroir secteur on
appelait même caractérisé même comme
fachos chirac ça me fait pas mal de
peine de voir cette étiquette
voilà c'est pas le chirac des années
2000 où il est à l'elysée où il a pris
plus de surface cuche de hauteur
oui s'est engagé sur la scène
internationale de façon très déterminée
donc il ya une évolution dans sa
personne une évolution c'est compatible
de passer de fachos chirac à fachoda
pardon à jacques chirac le libéral avec
un jacques chirac est beaucoup plus
social c'est pas jacques chirac le
libéral c'est de chirac père de la
nation si vous permettez ce qui explique
les motions extraordinairement profonde
et général d'ailleurs qui est apparu au
moment de sa mort il ya tout juste un an
oui il est normal que avec le temps on
prenne de l'épaisseur et que la vraie
personnalité se révèle la vraie
personnalité de girac c'est pas c'est
pas l'excès c'est pas le sectarisme
c'est au contraire une ouverture
d'esprit
il était très sensible à la diversité
des cultures du monde lui qui se piquait
d'inculture était en réalité dans
extrêmement cultivé et humanisme ce fil
conducteur c'est quand même le respect
de la dignité de la personne humaine et
notamment son attention aux plus
fragiles quand j'étais en corrèze
pendant ma campagne de la primaire je
suis allé dans une institution qui
accueille des enfants autistes et qui a
était patronné par la fondation jacques
chirac elle tous les handicapés de
france savent qu'ils leur doivent qui
lui doivent pardon les grands de loi sur
le handicap qu'il a tenu à faire adopter
par le parlement
de même qu'il a lancé le plan cancer a
paris je l'évoquent dans mon livre une
création aussi qui lui appartient que le
samu social qui prouvaient cette
attention aux plus faibles on s'en
serait bien d'ailleurs dans ce livre que
vous décrivez l'homme mais vous voulez
aussi réhabiliter une forme de bilan
d'action politique parce que souvent
jacques chirac pour les français c'était
un peu chichis c'était ce lien de
proximité
cette possibilité cette incarnation
l'identification que les français avec
avait avec lui ça n'est pas que ça pour
vous c'est ça d'abord et c'est très
important pour un chef d'état à avoir
cette empathie avec son peuple
quelque chose
que beaucoup recherchent et que peu
obtiennent donc c'est très important
mais il ya aussi un bilan de l'action de
jacques chirac qui est tout à fait
considérable je n'en prendrai que deux
exemples si aujourd'hui nous avons comme
monnaie unique l'euro qui nous protègent
contre bien des turbulences du monde
actuel et même les antieuropéens le
reconnaissent aujourd'hui on le doit en
grande partie à jacques chirac
parce que 92 au moment du référendum de
maastricht il a pris position pour le
oui
alors que les principaux leaders de son
portier pour le dréan nous on va en
parlais tout à l'heure avec richard vers
l'est justement je leur parce que la
hausse il a évolué et ensuite pardon
mais quand j'étais premier ministre on a
tout fait pour que la france se qualifie
pour l'euro donc à cet héritage européen
de jacques chirac est très très
important et puis il ya un autre
héritage dont je veux parler aujourd'hui
qui est particulièrement actuel 2002
maison brûle et on regarde ailleurs
et aujourd'hui le brésil brûle brûle la
californie brûle il s'est pas contenté
de le dire
il a fait adopter une loi
constitutionnelle en mars 2015 qui
inscrit dans nos institutions la charte
de l'environnement qui affirme
précisément que la sauvegarde de la
nature de la biodiversité la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique sont
des valeurs constitutionnelles
aujourd'hui le conseil constitutionnel
veille et veillera demain leur respect
pour l'action politique le réformateur
on revient quand même sur sur votre lien
je vous propose de regarder le sujet
préparé par stéphanie des pierres sur ce
couple inédit ce couple politique au
fond que tout oppose et qui est
inséparable encore aujourd'hui regardez
il s'agit de vous et de lui c'est l'une
des rares images ou alain juppé l'espère
si son émotion
jacques chirac vient de mourir ce soir
j'ai de la peine
beaucoup de peine
jacques chirac était je ne suis pas
trouver les mots
plus qu'un ami pas tout à fait un père
un homme politique avec lequel j'ai
entretenu pendant quarante ans une
relation de confiance de compréhension
de fidélité réciproque la fin d'une
amitié singulière l'une des plus longues
de l'histoire politique française
1976 normalien les inspecteurs des
finances alain juppé entre au cabinet du
premier ministre
il sera désormais la plume de jacques
chirac alain juppé devient le fidèle
lieutenant de jacques chirac
en campagne à la mairie de paris au
gouvernement et aux partis l'inséparable
tandem va faire du rpr une machine à
gagner et tout fait toutes les
tentatives de putsch au sein de la
famille gaulliste je voudrais exprimer
les sentiments que nous éprouvons tous à
l'égard de celui qui est probablement le
meilleur d'entre nous notre secrétaire
général alain gebel une déclaration
symbolique de leur très grande proximité
intellectuelle et morale tout en pudeur
père jacques chirac
si vous me permettez pour une fois cette
petite familiarité chaire jacques
parlez nous de la vence mai 1995 jacques
chirac remporté la présidentielle la
droite exulte alain juppé est à ses
côtés toujours dans la foule puis à
matignon pour services rendus
jacques chirac le nomme premier ministre
l'état de grâce ne dure pas à l'automne
les fonctionnaires sont dans la rue
contre la réforme des retraites
impopulaire contesté dans son propre
camp alain juppé sur la sellette
mais le duo tient le choc je fais toute
confiance à la lucidité et au courant
que des biens au cours du premier min
et pourtant quelques mois plus tard coup
de tonnerre j'ai décidé de dissoudre
l'assemblée nationale la gauche
l'emportent
alain juppé doit quitter matignon en
2004 il est condamné dans la sphère des
emplois fictifs à la mairie de paris
jacques chirac accuse le coup
sans désavouer son fidèle collaborateur
c'est un homme politique d'une très
grande d'une qualité exceptionnelle de
compétences d'humanisme d'honnêteté et
la france a besoin d'hommes de sa
qualité
depuis alain juppé revenu en politique
mais il n'a pas exactement suivi la
trajectoire de son mentor il a échoué à
conquérir l'elysée sur l'avant dernière
marche la primaire de la droite et je
salue richard wehrli qui nous a rejoint
bouffard soir chroniqueur dans cette
émission et correspondant parisien du
quotidien suisse le temps qualité
exceptionnelle vous avez entendu jacques
chirac de compétences d'humanisme et
cette phrase restée dans l'histoire
le meilleur d'entre nous honnêtement sa
porte
au contraire c'est difficile à porter au
havre les deux ça fait plaisir bien
entendu et en même temps ça suscite
beaucoup de jalousie alors je suis
toujours sur le probablement encore une
lueur d'espoir pour mes camarades
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que nous
étions deux hommes que tout oppose et
non je ne pense pas nous étions
différents bien sûr nous avions beaucoup
de points communs
peut-être un fidèle aux origines
sociales d'une moyenne bourgeoisie
ensuite cette timidité ou cette pudeur
on dira comme on veut qu'ils pourraient
apparaître comme de la dureté g chira du
tout la même manière de la gérer
peut-être oui m'enfin souvenez-vous
pendant longtemps fachos chirac n'était
pas quelqu'un de tendre un donc
ça a évolué avec le temps donc voila
nous avions beaucoup point commun et
surtout une vision commune sur beaucoup
de sujets sur l'europe sur le
développement durable sur d'autres
grands combats de jacques chirac
quand on retrace cette période ce qui me
concerne ça m'amuse beaucoup depuis que
j'ai écrit ses livres on ne parle que de
mes échecs les manifestations de
décembre 95
le procès et ses jeux pas envie de me
parler mais réussit mais il ya eu quand
même mais nous avons fait beaucoup de
belles réformes en 95 la réforme de
l'assurance maladie a été fait
ça m'amuse de voir qu'aujourd'hui ce que
j'avais créé à l'époque la caisse
d'amortissement de la dette sociale
existe toujours et sa vie et même
prolonger pendant plusieurs années pour
nous avons fait dans d'autres réformes
j'étais très heureux aussi d'être élu
pendant 12 ans du xviiie arrondissement
de paris je me suis beaucoup investi
dans sept arrondissements les plus
grandes fiertés ça a été aussi bien sur
l'or chirac n'était pas présent ça a été
bien sûr la ville de bordeaux et les
presque quart de siècle que j'ai passées
à la mairie
vous parlez de ces années matignon 95-97
vous décrivez aussi parfois la solitude
du pouvoir c'est une période où la
droite
et voilà en situation de tension et
pourtant jusqu'au bout jusqu'à la
décision de la dissolution et son
résultat
j'accepte ou le soutien il est vous
aurez garder premier ministre certains
ont interprété la dissolution de la
manière suivante jacques chirac ne
voulait pas changer de premier ministre
je lui avais remis mon mandat à la fin
de 96 parce que mon impopularité avait
du mal à se corriger
il a refusé et il a fait savoir beaucoup
de gens autour de lui qu'il ne
changerait pas pour les ministres
et comme il fallait provoquer un choc
politique certains ont considéré que
voilà c'était la dissolution est
recommandé tout cas il ne m'a jamais
retiré sa confiance et de même moi je
lui ai toujours manifesté la mienne
comment a germé d'aider la dissolution
parce que la déception avons oublié
vraiment personne le ceva dominique de
villepin nous retrouverons qu'assume le
général délégué
replacé dans le contexte si vous voulez
je vous ai dit que jacques chirac
chercher un moyen de relancer l'action
politique deuxièmement on a complètement
oublié ça tous les sondages nous donner
une perspective de victoire
même le ministre de l'intérieur qui
était jean louis debré à l'époque disait
il y à une raisonnable quelle raison de
penser afin de tabler sur la sur le
succès donc on n'est pas parti dans le
mur en sachant qu'on allait échouer
penser gagner naturellement ce qui a
péché dans cette campagne c'est de
convaincre les français de l'objectif
qui était le nôtre on n'a pas su donner
du sens à la dissolution
pour moi le sens était claire il fallait
que de nos qualifiant 81,18 pour entrer
dans l'euro et nous n'étions pas prêts
pas tout à fait prêt le déficit était
très important la dette etc
il fallait encore des sacrifices
importants a demandé au peuple français
et c'est ça que je voulais faire au
moment de la campagne des législatives a
convaincu que christian a parlé de
l'europe
résultat on a parlé de rien encore été
battu alors je continue un tout petit
peu a déroulé dans le temps mais on en
vient bientôt à à l'europe vous parlez
de paris député du xviiie arrondissement
forcément cette phrase aussi est resté
dans l'histoire
comment voulez vous
que le travailleur français qui habite à
la goutte d'or où je peux promener avec
alain juppé est le dernier à 34 jours et
qui travaille avec sa part et qui
ensemble gagne environ 15000 francs et
qu'ils voient sur le palier à côté de
son hlm entassée une famille avec un
père de famille trois ou quatre épouses
et une vingtaine de gosses et guigal
cinquante mille fois prestations
sociales sans naturellement travailler
[Applaudissements]
ajoutez à cela le bruit et l'odeur est
bien le travail en français sur le
palier bien fou à jacques chirac
il s'est excusé après ces mots il a
connu une bêtise
or je pense ce passage de mon livre a
beaucoup de succès cité par le site
systématiquement savez face à céder sur
le fond face à nous sur la forme et sur
les mots employés
est ce qu'on regarde la réalité en face
ou pas est-ce que ce qu'il dit est faux
ou vrai moi j'ai été l'une ou 100 g les
mots décrivent la réalité on peut
refaire oui le bruit ça existe nous
avons là des communautés qui n'ont pas
les mêmes habitudes de vie qui font la
fête
une grande partie dans la nuit alors que
d'autres communautés ont envie de dormir
c'est une réalité que décrit jacques
chirac et moi je suis pas quelqu'un
déterré j'ai été élu 12 ans dans ce
quartier et donc c'est une réalité
le déni est quelque chose qui nous
conduit à la situation actuelle où à le
quartier de la doutre au nord est re
devenu invivable
qu'est ce qu'on a fait à l'époque parce
que dans la foulée de ce que dit jacques
chirac il ya deux attitudes possibles
la première c'est l'exclusion ces gens
là on n'en veut pas jacques chirac a
totalement été étranger à ce genre de
comportement le racisme a été quelque
chose qui l'a exécré tout au long de sa
carrière politique et l'autre attitude
c'est de chercher à intégrer
et qu'est ce que j'ai fait à la goutte
d'or géant engagé avec le soutien de
l'état d'ailleurs à l'époque à
formidable programme de rénovation des
bâtiments de création d'équipements
publics des crèches des écoles
concertation et de concertation avec les
associations de la ville en matière
d'intégration n'est pas bon que de la
goutte d'or
ça c'est autre chose bien sûr que
c'était l'échec que c'est pas des
chèques de chirac
c'est à l'échec de la france depuis 30
ans et aujourd'hui la goutte d'or est en
pleine émotion ou un plein je n'ai pas
de révolution mais en pleine agitation
parce que les conditions de vie s'ils
sont beaucoup dégradées donc ça devrait
nous inspirer non pas peut-être quelque
chose de choquant dans ce qui est des
chirac il l'a dit peut-être mais en tout
cas faire le qui veut faire l'ange fait
la bête si on refuse de regarder cette
réalité en face on se retrouve devant
alors le succès du coup c'est compatible
parler d'identité heureuse alors où la
question identitaire remonte christ
alors où les peurs voilà est-ce que
c'est compréhensible peut-être été
compris s'il avait été conduite j'aurais
été élu et je persiste et je signe
d'abord je suis fier de mon identité
tous les français sont fiers d'être
français
l'identité c'est cela l'identité
française c'est quoi c'est la démocratie
c'est la république c'est les valeurs
républicaines et c'est l'humanisme c'est
ça l'identité heureuse je n'ai jamais
prétendu que tous les français étaient
heureux et pour avoir été les élus de ce
quartier pendant 12 ans j'y reviens je
sais ce que c'est que les difficultés de
la vie quotidienne
mais vous imaginez un homme politique
qui brigue la présidence de la
république
et qui dit à ses concitoyens ce que je
vous propose c'est d'être un peu plus
malheureux demain qu'aujourd'hui vous
passez vos c'était de leur dire ya de
l'espoir
on peut redevenir dans une communauté
nationale qui partagent les mêmes
valeurs on peut retrouver le chemin d'un
bonheur collectif en étant fidèle à nos
racines à notre identité
voilà ce que c'est et l'identité
heureuse je les bats l'expliqué ce
n'était peut-être pas ce qu'attendaient
les françaises et les français
whissell le prix mode recul avec la vie
politique j'étais décidée depuis bien
longtemps a décroché à 75 ans je pense
qu'il ya un temps pour tout il ya le
temps de l'action et puis le temps de la
sagesse alors évidemment aujourd'hui je
pourrais m'interroger
quand je vois l'âge moyen des candidats
à la présidence des sociétés je me dis
que 75 ans n'est peut-être pas une barre
à 78 oui sanders 79 est propre et non
moins que moi que vous connaissez bien
ça m'amuse ne change pas bon même
profession
moi j'ai très heureux aux conséquences
j'ai le sentiment d'y faire un travail
utile parce qu'aujourd'hui la défense
des droits et libertés de nos
concitoyens est un enjeu extrêmement
important avant de parler d'europe
voudrais parler un tout petit peu des
personnages que l'on rencontre au fur et
à mesure de vos pages nicolas sarkozy
forcément vous le rencontrer dès 1976 et
vous avez cette formule cheveux en
bataille j'essaye de retrouver la
formule tignasse en bataille verbe
exubérant cordialité cultivé et vous
dites il m'a impressionné
il a impressionné d'emblée c'est vrai il
avait impressionné chirac d'ailleurs qui
avaient détecté parce que je savais
faire ça à détecter les valeurs de
demain les hommes et les femmes qui
n'avaient envie d'attirer autour de lui
et sarkozy m'a toujours impressionné il
a une espèce de d'énergie vitale en lui
et cette façon de s'emparer de son
interlocuteur jusqu'à les toucher qui
est extrêmement efficace donc voilà j'ai
une forme
voilà ce que le mot est trop fort george
aberration voilà c'est vous qui l'avez
dit vous raconter même et c'est une
arrivée des révélations du livre que en
1999 échec cinglant pour nicolas sarkozy
aux européennes ils vous proposent un
effort de tickets vous effectivement
vous n'êtes plus aux affaires on est
après la transition et de la dissolution
de 90 heures et vous dit si on va
préparer la présidentielle à 2 oui oui
absolument ont fait un binôme alors à
l'époque c'était moi numéro un le numéro
deux après ça a changé et je lui dis ps
que tu n'as pas peur que nous
apparaissions aux yeux des français
comme des losers à cause justement de
son échec aux européennes est beau échec
aux législatives
et alors là j'ai cru qui s'étrangle est
l'idée que lui pouvait être perdants ne
le traverse et pas l'esprit peut-être
ai-je été trop modeste ce qui me
concerne ça revient souvent à cette
question finalement de l'envy lanville
envie de suivre
bien sûr que les hommes politiques sont
tombés sur vous
n'assumez pas les contraintes énormes
que qu'implique la vie politique il n'ya
pas que ça et j'essaie de montrer dans
mon livre aussi que ce qui m'a le plus
réunies à jacques chirac
c'est notre vision de l'engagement
politique et de sa noblesse
nous avons pensé salaire un peu naïf de
dire ça aujourd'hui ça fera sans doute
sourire
nous avons pensé qu' on peut avoir à
l'idéal en politique et cet idéal c'est
d'améliorer la condition de ses
concitoyens c'est pour ça qu'on se lance
dans la vie politique je crois très
profondément
en tout cas les vrais hommes politiques
j'ai cité dans une interview cette
anecdote qui m'a beaucoup marqué du plus
jeune maire de france
j'ai vu ça à la télé a pas longtemps qui
vient d'être réduit la 19 ans totalement
inexpérimentés il est dans son village
heureux et il dit je vais faire revivre
mon village je vais attirer des
commerces je vais attirer des
entreprises et donc si s'est engagé dans
la vie publique c'est parce qu'ils y
croient la question du désir et de
l'envié on en vient à l'europe
est ce que jacques chirac comme nicolas
sarkozy n'avait pas un goût que
peut-être vous n'avez pas c'est celui de
brusquer les événements peut-être
peut-être je le dis avec le recul je
n'ai peut-être pas été dévorés comme ils
l'ont été par l'ambition d'être
président de la république je ne sais
plus lequel des deux a dit qu'il ait
pensé même en se rasant le matin on vous
savez sans doute qu'ils l'europe
l'europe et jacques chirac
effectivement parce que il y à cet
héritage européen dont vous parliez que
vous avez mis en valeur mais il ya aussi
une ambiguïté européenne qu'on a
injustement selon vous reprochés à
jacques chirac alors j'ai lu votre livre
et j'ai trouv peut-être trouvé la raison
de cette ambiguïté page 65
c'est une phrase où vous vous êtes en
train de raconter ce qui lui a beaucoup
été reprochée c'est l'appel de cochin du
6 décembre 1978 il dénonce le parti de
l'étranger
c'est interprété comme une attaque
directe contre valéry giscard d'estaing
vous raconter que cet appel a été non
seulement inspiré par ses deux
conseillers marie france garaud et
pierre juillet mais qu'ils en ont même
peut-être travesti lé contenu qui l'a
presque découvert au dernier moment
alors que dit cette phrase page 65 vous
dit
au total vous ne pratiquez pas vous vous
adressez à jacques chirac vous ne
pratiquez pas l'exercice solitaire du
pouvoir et je pense que c'était plus une
force et une faiblesse alors vous voici
obligés de reconnaître
le tiraillement perpétuelle de jacques
chirac qui d'un côté avait des
convictions mais de l'autre avaient
déconseillé
c'était un chef de meute qu'il
travaillait à la tête d'un clan et salue
la quand même beaucoup coûté alors vous
êtes sur ce point très ambivalents vous
dit peut-on vous reprocher d'avoir su
vous entouré de conseillers aussi
puissant non parce qu en conciliant des
points de vue différents
c'était pour vous la garantie de
conserver votre liberté alors ma
question sera simple est-ce que sur un
dossier comme l'europe
jacques chirac n'a t-il pas un peu trop
souvent écouté ses conseillers au lieu
d'écouter sa passion et ses convictions
on sent qu'il ya deux questions dans
votre propos la première sur l'europe le
meuble elle-même l'appel de cochin vous
avez rappelé de quoi il s'agit c'est
tout le monde un peu oublié ce texte qui
était très violent dans le parti de
l'étranger qui était certainement
dirigée contre jets skis dont vous dit
qu'il l'a découvert
bien sûr au moi je peux porter
témoignage de ce qui s'est passé ce mois
chirac venait de subir d'être victime
d'un accident de la circulation très
grave
il était sur son lit de douleur à cochin
je lui ai rendu visite et et le voit il
était conscient naturellement mais en
souffrance est vraiment très près s'est
rangé à ce qui se passait dans la vie
politique et on lui a fait signer un
papier qu'il a par lui quand je dis on
c'est juillet et garou et jacques chirac
le dit lui même dans ses mémoires
c'est en moi qui l'a inventé j'avais eu
la prescience le pressentiment
il le confirme et donc à ce moment là
c'est vrai j'en viens à la deuxième
partie de votre question parce que sur
l'europe on pourrait poursuivre j'ai la
conviction que même s'il n'a pas été un
passionné de l'europe
chirac a travaillé au progrès de
l'europe j'en ai parlé à propos de
l'euro mais à d'autres sujets notamment
la défense européenne où il a pris
beaucoup d'initiatives
l'autre sujet c'est est il sous
influence encore il ya plusieurs chirac
ya le chirac de ces années 70 oui c'est
vrai il a été trop longtemps sous
l'influencé de deux conseillers qu'il
avait hérité de pompidou c'est pour ça
qu'ils avaient beaucoup d' influence sur
lui et il a fallu le clash de l'appel de
cochin puis des élections européennes
pour qu'il s'en débarrasse
mais ce que c'est vraiment le cas après
pardon de vous interpeller
si on prend ce que vous dites dans votre
et furent edouard balladur j'y viens
vous dit
j'étais sidéré par la façon dont à tout
propos
en s'adressant à chirac vous appeliez
edwards au téléphone pour recueillir son
avis sur tel ou tel événement sur telle
ou telle décision
un homme finalement qui est quand même
resté longtemps sous influence
donc j'y viens il ya eu la période garou
juillet puis après des années 80 où là
effectivement balladur a eu une
influence très forte jamais été témoin
c'était toujours le pompidolisme
balladur était un des proches
collaborateurs de pompidou et c'est à la
fin des années 80 au début des années 90
que jacques chirac s'est libéré de ses
influences camp balladur l'a trahi il a
des phrases très très très forte là
dessus sur la déception qu'il a
éprouvées je peux vous dire qu ensuite
et ça a été l'essentiel de sa vie
politique entre 93 et 2007
chirac président là il avait c'est vrai
une pluralité de conseillers autour de
lui et tant mieux
c'est ça que je salue parce que d'hommes
politiques ne doit pas être isolé mais
il savait jouer sur les uns les autres
pour se faire sa propre idée ça faire sa
propre décision nous et à une évolution
dans le comportement et prononcez le mot
de trahison d'autres ont trahi à par
edouard balladur
ça leur a plutôt réussi ils ont été élus
je pense à emmanuel macron avec françois
hollande ou encore nicolas sarkozy
candidat de la rupture avec avec jacques
chirac on peut remonter convoi greben
loin loges de la trahison et la loyauté
et sport boules a forcément à edouard
philippe qui peut rendre possible toutes
les ambitions je disais que ce couple
président en premier ministre pour tirer
le char ne l'est pas j'utilise cette
image un peu classique était assez
exceptionnelle de gaulle et pompidou se
finit mal
météo giscard et chirac ça fait mal
mitterrand c'est rocard
ça finit mal il était papa ministre
enfin aux landais macron voilà et nous
on est restés confiants l'un dans
l'autre jusqu'au bout et c'est ça qui
est d'assez exceptionnel et d'assez
singulier et c'est ça qui fait que j'ai
ressenti avec une très forte émotion sa
disparition je crois que je le dis tout
à fait au début du livre lorsque grâce à
à claude je suis à son chevet alors
qu'il est déjà pratiquement à la veille
de la mort et où j'ai pu passer ce grand
moment avec lui pour vivre certaine
manière 40 ans de vie commune et ça
s'appelle mon chirac
une amitié singulière c'est aux éditions
au taillandier merci beaucoup ri cha
merci infiniment
alain juppé doit être bâtie sur le
plateau d' lcp tout de suite un dialogue
inédit entre une jeune romancière à
succès et un ministre sur les nouvelles
formes d'engagement politique
[Musique]
bonsoir aller zeniter et merci
infiniment d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes l'une des
sensations littéraire de cette rentrée
après l'art de perdre qui a été un
énorme succès 500000 exemplaires vendus
si on compte les poches c'est énorme
c'est extraordinaire vous publiez ce
livre comme un empire dans un empire
c'est toujours chez flammarion
et c'est un roman qui explorent les
différents visages de l'engagement en
politique on va y revenir longuement
parce que ce roman figurez vous qu'il se
déroule pour partie ici même à
l'assemblée nationale au palais bourbon
jusqu'où doit-on aller pour changer le
monde
au fond c'est l'une des questions que
vous posez dans ce livre dont on va
débattre de cette question avec vous
marc fesneau
bonsoir c'est un plaisir de vous avoir
sur ce débat vous allez voir il n'aura
rien à voir avec les interviews
politiques traditionnels vous êtes un
ministre délégué en charge des relations
avec le parlement élu député du loir et
cher et vous avez un
l'on passé comme antoine l'un de vos
personnages ali sanitaire dans ce livre
d'assistants parlementaires alors on va
essayer de comprendre ce qu'est un
assistant parlementaire ici votre
perception des choses rejoint celle de
marc fesneau enfin bonsoir fanuel héros
choix merci d'être là vous êtes le porte
parole de l'association l214 qui on le
sait bien se bat pour le bien-être
animal on connaît vos vidéos chocs
tourné en caméra cachée dans les
abattoirs faut-il des moyens parfois
illégaux pour alerter et pour peser sur
la société pour faire en sorte que et
bien peut-être cette question devienne
force de loi voilà pour le décor mais
j'aurais d'abord qu'on revienne un peu
sur votre parcours politique rabique a
suivi à la fois votre rencontre avec
votre public et quelques quelques
éléments de biographie regarder à la fin
de l'entretien les deux éditeurs lui
avait demandé de leur envoyer un
chapitre antoine avait opinait
rapidement comme si le chapitre avait
été prêt
la voix est posée le public absorber ces
mots ce sont ceux d'alice zeniter
l'auteur est sur scène ce soir pour
présenter son sixième roman comme un
empire dans un empire un livre sur
l'engagement politique
peut-être que l'engagement peut être
réceptif
et en tout cas ça vaut peut-être le coup
de s'engager quand même alors il va
mettre des mots très très précis très
juste sur des réalités à la fois
personnelles ou contemporaines et c'est
ça qui me plaît beaucoup danser danser
les prix tous les messages importants
aux quelque sorte derrière sur une sur
les identités sur les questions
politiques traverse d'autres deviennent
performatif en fait donc c'est chaud
c'est ça que très très intéressant quoi
à 34 ans alice zeniter a déjà son public
son dernier roman l'art de perdre s'est
vendu à 500 mille exemplaires dans ce
livre elle plonge le lecteur dans
l'histoire d'une famille entre l'algérie
et la france sur trois générations pour
ce roman la petite fille de harki
décroche l'un des prix littéraires les
plus prestigieux le goncourt des lycéens
c'est très difficile d'exprimer sa joie
en étant original vous êtes une
génération je vais pleurer
vous êtes une génération qui vient après
moi et avec qui j'ai pu partager cette
histoire
un succès qu'il a définitivement fait
passer dans la cour des grands moi je
les lui la première fois avec son bras
dimanche et trouvait que c'était
étonnant de maîtrise pour une jeune
auteur comme ça et puis elle n'a cessé
de progresser
l'art de perdre le précédent il ya un
roman éblouissant je pense que c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui est d'ores et
déjà importants et il va le devenir de
plus en plus auteur précoce tout jeune
déjà ali zeniter dribble avec les mots
comme d'autres jouent au ballon
son passe temps favori réécrire avec ses
soeurs les livres des grands auteurs ont
ressuscité des personnages secondaires
qui mouraient alors qu'ont trouvé ça
injuste et puis et puis parfois de
manière totalement égoïste ont inséré
nos personnages pour pouvoir vivre dans
ce monde là qui nous faisait tellement
rêver mais qui dans un livre clos nous
laissait nous laisser à la porte quoi à
seulement 16 ans elle publie son premier
livre de sa chambre de lycéenne elle
écrit le destin de deux enfants perdus
en pleine guerre de bosnie
de fermer la porte de mettre de la
musique pas des musiques avec des
paroles sinon j'écoute les paroles mais
d'avoir de la musique en fond personne
qui vient de déranger et d'être là sur
la moquette et de santé walk est d'avoir
le crayon dans la main et d'avoir les
feuilles sous les 20 même le bruit du
crayon papier sur la feuille on voit en
votes les mots prennent forme puis on
l'entend et à la fois on le touche
vous avez 16 ans sur ces images vous
écriviez déjà qu'est ce que c'est
précoce alors on vous ramène toujours à
ce côté là un peu prodige de la
littérature vous êtes vous êtes fier de
sa doudou ça vous vient cet amour des
mots et de l'écriture si jeune alors je
saurai pas je saurai pas le dire
pourquoi est-ce qu'un jeu nous plaît
plus qu'un autre il se joue là des
choses tellement multiples que j'ai
jamais identifié des raisons précises et
je sais pas si je suis fier en revanche
que je sais c'est que je suis très
heureuse d'avoir pu commencé à bricoler
avec les mots avant vraiment de
découvrir la littérature comme comme
quelque chose que j'admirais temps
qu'elle aurait pu m'écraser finalement
au moment où j'ai découvert un peu ce
qu'était le panthéon des grands auteurs
et et voilà et cette littérature un peu
comme une boule de lumière qui planait
au dessus de moi ça faisait déjà dix ans
que je bricolais dans mon coin et coller
avec les mots vous avez été aussi une
excellente élève vous est normalienne et
en même temps vous êtes devenu un
écrivain
comment on passe de la bonne élève à
l'écrire parce qu'on a envie de raconter
je pensais parce qu'on voit aussi enfin
en tout cas moi c'est mon cas j'avais
l'impression de voir des mise en récit
tout le temps là ou là où on les cherche
pas forcément c'est à dire en dehors des
livres c'est de me dire attendre ce
journal télévision c'est pas vrai que
c'est des informations c'est une mise en
récit est peut-être que cette mise en
récit elle me va pas cette manière de
raconter une journée cette manière de
qualifier les gens les noms qu'on pose
sur les gens ou sur sur les choses ou
sur une classe sociale en entier j'ai
envie de m'arrêter de questionner ce nom
et de direction change le nom est ce que
ça change pas l'histoire qu'on raconte
aussi
c'est impressionnant comme parcours vous
avez réalisé ni terre marc fesneau bon
j'avoue humblement je n'ai pas lu asie
lisez nikkei mais du coup ça me donne
envie de vous lire alors pourquoi il
faut lire particulièrement ce livre
comme un titre du précédent m'interroge
aussi donc ça donne envie d'en lire deux
mois à l'art de perdre c'est une autre
histoire
tout est bon alors perdre comme titre
c'est vrai c'est un art aussi perdre et
c'est pas toujours non ils perdraient
thon rouge
et c'est pas toujours voilà quelque
chose qui ait vécu de ce point de vue
artistique
alors comme un empire dans un empire
vous écrivez deux facettes de
l'engagement de jeunes il ya antoine qui
est assistant parlementaire je le disais
il ya elle qui a que deux proches du
mouvement des anonymous
vous aviez envie on le comprend très
bien de deux jeunes de deux vit au fond
un peu normal un peu banal surtout pas
de personnalités politiques vous voulez
montrer un militantisme de vrais gens
dans la vraie vie pourquoi parce que je
pense que du coup ça a grandi aussi
l'idée de qu'est ce que c'est
l'idée de la société et de kif et le
politique et la réponse c'est tout le
monde et vous disiez en introduction que
c'est un livre sur ceux qui veulent
changer le monde et en fait c'est pas
exactement ça c'est un livre sur des
personnages qui sont totalement
insatisfaits du monde mais insatisfaits
à un point qui en qui en devient presque
douloureux sert quand il voit une
situation dont ils pensent ça ne me va
pas ça leur met un coup au ventre et ils
se sentent du coup dans une obligation
de faire quelque chose en ayant des
moyens extrêmement réduit et ça de dire
aussi on va pas laisser la politique aux
grands hommes à ceux dont on voit les
noms sur une sur une frise chronologique
ou dans les livres d'histoire c'est
aussi quelque chose qui se fait par les
petites vies par par des mouvements de
masse par ceux dont on a oublié les noms
et moi je leur redonne voilà je leur
redonne des prénoms surtout et
et c'est un livre sur la lutte on
s'engage on se résigne pas mais parfois
la cause a les plus grandes que vous et
donc ça crée de la frustration et
particulièrement ici même dans ce
milieux parlementaires et antoine
parfois voilà il ya un peu il y un peu
désabusé c'est difficile
racontez-nous y travaille pour un
parlementaire de l'opposition à
socialiste comment vous savez travaillez
déjà vous avez on vous a ouvert un petit
peu les portes raconte ému alors moi
j'avais déjà fait mes recherches de mon
côté mais ça reste et ça restait assez
lointain et puis à un moment donné j'ai
rencontré françois ruffin qui qui avait
lui l'art de perdre lui même à écrire un
très beau livre sur sur les anciens
harkis et leurs familles amiens qui
s'appelle quartiers nord donc on s'est
rencontrés pour pour échanger sur ça et
puis on a fait aussi une partie de
baby-foot et dans dans ce lâcher prise
qui arrivait dans la partie de baby-foot
j'ai osé dire j'écris sur un assistant
parlementaire et en même temps j'ai
jamais mis les pieds dans les bureaux de
l'assemblée est ce que ce serait
possible et il m'a ouvert les portes de
chez lui si on peut appeler ça chez lui
donc j'ai pu passer du temps avec ses
assistants et quels regards alors vous
découvrez quoi la vie des bureaux la
cantine oui et cette chose aussi qui est
que en fait on fait un travail qui est
caché puisque le les bureaux du 101 rue
de l'université
c'est pas eux qu'on filme on va montrer
le palais bourbon avec la beauté en même
temps la beauté un peu écrasante des ors
de la république
mais tout ce travail là qui se fait dans
les bureaux et dont on ne sait pas en
fait qu'est-ce qui va passer c'est ça la
frustration d'antoine aussi c'est de se
dire je passe mon temps à produire des
textes des idées j'ai aucune idée de ce
que mon employeur va garder et quand ils
gardent quelque chose je sais pas du
tout ce qui va pouvoir passer en séance
oui et ça c'est une frustration de tous
les assistants ou pas comment on pèse
sur les textes racontez nous votre
expérience parce que au fond sa
désillusion là est ce que vous vous là
vous l'avez connu vous aussi dans ce
parcours je pense que je veux dire sur
moi ce en faire une généralisation ce
que je pense que ça tient beaucoup au
tempérament au fond j'ai été
collaborateur de jacqueline gourault au
sénat ce qui n'est pas tout à fait la
même maison
je dis humblement je n'ai jamais eu le
sentiment de frustration des
frustrations collective éventuellement
politique et qu'on a toujours dans la
vie politique et des frustrations
personnelles
sauf à ce que j'ai voulu me voulu moi
même masquer mes frustrations à moi même
parce que vous peut-être vous étiez dans
la majorité à l'époque au sénat ce qui
est alternatif mais au fond j'ai
toujours le rôle de collaborateur
collaborateurs parlementaires de vous
parler dont on parle est un rôle très
particulier parce que c'est un rôle à la
fois où on est très liée aux
parlementaires avec lequel on travaille
c'est une forme de fusion entre le
parlementaire et son collaborateur et en
même temps vous êtes très effacé
vis-à-vis de votre parlementaires parce
que c'est lui qui qui qui est celui qui
exprime quelque chose politique mais la
difficulté c'est parfois de de penser
qu'on exprime sa propre pensée que c'est
le député ou sénateur vient de venir
devient votre porte parole au fond c'est
la question si le risque c'est celui là
de dire au fond je pars espèce de
transfert je deviens le le député ou
sénateur devient mon porte parole or
c'est je pense pas que ce soit alors
chacun trouve sa place comme mieux et
comme il peut d'ailleurs dans ce
contexte là puis ça dépend des
parlementaires j'ai une relation très
longue avec jacqueline gourault qui
s'est poursuivie et le hasard de la vie
et la malice de la vie on est désormais
dans le même gouvernement
mais c'était une relation et c'est une
relation guerre qui se poursuit parce
que c'est une relation où on vit des
épisodes 2 victoires 2 défaites
mais c'était une relation qui était
plutôt une relation je ne ne considérait
pas que j'étais dans ce rôle là j'étais
donc et j'acceptais assez volontiers
compris quand on fait une note
on a le sentiment auquel n'a pas été lu
qu'elle était très profondément modifié
par rapport à ce qu'on avait
intuitivement penser au démarrage un
discours qu'on écrit qu' un discours
qu'on n'a pas renoncé à ses fusées je me
retrouve dans cette situation désormais
le collaborateur parlementaire c'est
quelqu'un qui finit par penser un peu où
être un peu comme le député mais il
n'est pas le député où il n'est pas le
sénateur et ses mécanismes de transfert
crée parfois me semble-t-il des
frustrations les frustrations de la vie
politique on en parlera peut-être un peu
après mais
ces frustrations là ça dépend de la
situation et la façon dont on aborde le
travail avec son parlementaire puis elle
personnage de llr vous avez découvert le
milieu du acquis du piratage
informatique
et là je vais me tourner vers vous
saluer les roues parce que cette forme
d'engagement que vous représentez depuis
toujours vous vous êtes dit il faut être
à la frontière à l'est même utiliser des
moyens d'action illégaux pour renverser
la table est posée puisque je rappelle
que vous faites des des caméras cachées
qui sont voilà des intrusions dans des
propriétés privées sait pas exactement
ce qu'on fait c'est vrai qu'il ya donc
tendance moment quelqu'un qui est
vraiment engagée politiquement auprès
des institutions près près de la
fabrique de la loi une autre personne
qui est vraiment non seulement dans
l'illégalité mais dans la clandestinité
nous je dirais qu'on est sur un pool
d'engagement qui finalement est très con
en france et c'est le pôle associatif il
ya un français sur quatre qui donne de
son temps bénévolement pour poser
associations culturelles sportives et
politiques aussi et c'est vrai que nous
nous donc on est une association
déclarée en les activités légales mais
sec nous on milite pour qui un cadre
légal qui protège les lanceurs d'alerté
on se fait le relais de leurs
informations et de leur image
parce que on pense que c'est
indispensable de protéger ces personnes
qui elle constate sur le terrain que la
loi est mal appliquée ou que la loi en
étant appliqué n'atteint pas son effet
et que les citoyens méritants est
informé et là j'en ai vraiment tous les
propos qui ont été tenus la politique ça
concerne tout le monde on fait tous
politiques en forme en fait société
ensemble on doit tous débattre échanger
pour décider des règles avec lesquelles
lesquels on vit et cette information sur
ce lien avec les réseaux sociaux oui
exactement votre action a été
démultipliée et parfois on a
l'impression que son efficacité aussi a
été démultipliée marcq raineau caen l214
fait une vidéo choc il ya immédiatement
forcément une réponse politique ou en
tout cas des mots avant une prise de
décisions législatives
oui je suis je partage ses sentiments
qui est celui que l'on fait peut on fait
on fait tous politique et que ce qui a
sans doute changé quand même c'est qu'au
fond
jusqu'à ya peut-être 10 15 ou 20 ans
peut-être que ça date de la chute du mur
de berlin au fond c'est le débat
politique était assez clivé assez
identifier et à s'est organisée autour
des partis politiques et ça n'est pas
lié qu'aux réseaux sociaux me
semble-t-il le progressif effacement du
rôle des partis politiques comme
structurant le débat politique a porté
des fruits qui sont très différents et
par ailleurs vous en ré ligne de fond du
rat comment je vais finir là-dessus je
vous répondrai mais les lignes de
fracture qui traditionnellement privé la
droite la gauche
me trouvant au centre c'est un peu
compliqué mais était assez identifié est
désormais convoyé les sujets qui sont
sur la table y compris les cause que
vous défendez ça n'est pas un sujet qui
vient marquer les lignes à l'intérieur
d'un parti politique et donc c'est un
vrai sujet me semble utile pour le monde
politique
pour le coup le monde politique que je
représente ce soir une certaine façon
que d'arriver à voir comment les partis
politiques peuvent serez en parle parce
que moi je pense qu'on a besoin quand
même pour structurer les choses de
partis politiques est ce que je regrette
je passe il faut regretter c'est un fait
la difficulté des réseaux sociaux c'est
alors la puissance de diffusion d'un
réseau social est incontestable et les
démentiel par rapport à ce qu'on a connu
il ya 20 ou 30 ans et compris par
rapport à ce qui était la puissance
télévisuelle après la tendance à je
trouve rendre plus violent le débat
public ce qu'il ya quelque chose de plus
tendu dans le réseau social
des sociologues ou des gens des
spécialistes de ces questions là le dire
est beaucoup mieux quoi ou sans doute
vous il ya quelque chose qui tend le
débat public alors qu'il est avec nous
des noms de sa politique pour le monde
venait parfois se soumet trop haute en
cours c'est vrai que c'est un puissant
accélérateur et lord le monde politique
a besoin aussi temps l'ont semble-t-il
on est là au fond dans des questions de
légitimité de l'engagement politique la
démocratie représentative
le monde associatif le monde du piratage
informatique sont tous légitimes ou pas
selon vous ces mondes là pour pour faire
changer le monde
moi je crois mais
comme samuel viens de le dire je crois
vraiment à une division du travail
engagé c'est d'ailleurs un discours qu
antoine va tenir dans le livre qui est
que il ya différentes formes d'actions
qui peuvent coexister et qui peuvent
être nécessaires et qu'il ne faut pas
juger ça selon les principes de la
morale qu ancien qui voudrait que tout
soit universalisable de dire et si tout
le monde faisait comme toi qu'est ce que
ça donnerait en fait si tout le monde
était à l'assemblée nationale
ça ne donnerait pas grand chose de bon
si tout le monde était pirates
informatiques ça ne donnerait pas non
plus grand chose de bon donc il faut
prendre en fait ce que c'est ce que ces
modes d'action nous nous permettent et
en l'occurrence oui il ya des actions
illégales qui peuvent faire bouger les
lignes en exemple les lanceurs d'alerté
par exemple si on pense à ce modèle
finalement lui fait une action illégale
mais pour révéler une action bien plus
massives lien plus puissante est tout
aussi illégal donc
donc on peut dire cette action est
absolument légitime et après on peut
dire aussi il faut qu' il ya un travail
institutionnel qui se fasse à côté après
en même temps je sais pas comment pour
que au delà au delà d'un cas isolé ou
d'une petite poignée de personnes les
changements qui sont demandées puisse
passer à grande échelle parce que quand
on affronte des ennemis qui sont très
grands quand on affronte des problèmes
qui sont systémiques et ben en fait une
poignée d'activistes peu juste attirer
l'attention mais pas faire le reste du
travail
d'où la nécessité de la coexistence
parle de coexistence de complémentarité
vous voyez des choses de la même manière
un activiste peut être l'alliée d'un élu
je partage presque tout ce que vous avez
dit la limite pour moi et à la place à
laquelle je suis je peux pas dire autre
chose mais c'est ce que je pense ou fond
n'est pas faux de dire qu'il ya de
grandes causes qui ont progressé parce
qu'au fond un certain nombre de gens se
sont affranchis de la légalité
c'est au fond pas très nouveau de ce
point de vue là je dirai ce que je sens
de nouveau les droits civiques aux états
unis
le droit à l'avortement c'est à procéder
quand même au démarrage d'actes illégaux
même temps ça peut pas être une
rhétorique permanente musan aussi c'est
un acte pour moi d' alerte est de mise
sur la scène publique d'un problème
la limite pour moi et dans le monde dans
lequel on vit je trouve que c'est là la
dérive un peu risqué en tout cas si on
veut faire avancer les causes séquence a
produit quelque chose qui est une forme
de violence faite à l'autre
c'est ça qui me pour moi quelque chose
et puis dans la philosophie qui est la
mienne d'aller me il ya quelque chose
qui ne peut pas être la violence
seulement fait à l'autre quand bien même
d'ailleurs ceux qui le font sont eux
mêmes victimes d'une forme de violence
morale ou sociale ou d'autres natures
deuxième élan la difficulté dans
laquelle on est me semble-t-il en ce
moment c'est que ce que vous décrivez
assez bien c'est à dire on met sur la
place publique après le cible du système
au bon sens du terme l'institutionnel se
saisit de la question est dans le cadre
institutionnel parce qu'il faut bien un
cadre institutionnel pour traiter des
questions on le transmet or aujourd'hui
et sans doute les réseaux sociaux ne
sont pas de seconde villa tout à fait
favorables ont fait émerger le problème
très rapidement et on a du mal à
construire après quelque chose qui est
de l'ordre de comment on avance et c'est
peut-être ça la difficulté par rapport à
ce qu'on a vécu des causes que
j'essayais de de t'écrire devant devant
vous qu'est ce que c'est plus difficile
compte tenu de ce que sont ces outils là
et de ski et l'ambiance de la société de
produire après 2 qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
quel est le compromis et qu'est-ce qu'on
fait avancer comme cause moi il me
semble que c'est une des difficultés qui
est devant nous merci on va s'arrêter là
je vais peut-être une toute dernière
question rapidement comme un empire dans
un empire
cette forme et ça vient d'une citation
de spinoza qui dit en réalité ils
conçoivent l'homme dans la nature comme
un empire dans un empire et qui est une
phrase par laquelle il essaye de
démontrer que on pense on pense notre
notre place d'une manière qui n'est pas
bonne alors on a mis en avant
complètement le libre arbitre la volonté
qui nous permettrait d'échapper au
déterminisme qui nous permettrait aussi
de nous penser en maître et possesseur
de la nature comme si l'homme était
était libre espinosa rappelle qu'il ne
l'est pas et dans mon livre j'essaye
aussi de regarder qu'est-ce qui
construit un personnage comment comment
il est entravée c'est quoi les liens
qu'il porte et qui vont aussi d'une
certaine manière l'empêcher de rêver ou
l'empêcher
vite et de manière paisible un espace
est de le partager avec d'autres formes
de vivant et c'est en librairie chez
flammarion merci beaucoup alice éditeur
vous restez avec nous marc fesneau va
terminer avec la chronique de thomas des
prêts alors ce soir il nous parle de ses
futurs jeunes papas qui dès l'année
prochaine vont pouvoir pouponner un peu
plus longtemps celle annonces
présidentielles du jour n'est ce pas
thomas où exactement myriam emmanuel
macron a annoncé un allongement de la
durée du congé paternité une annonce qui
fait presque consensus à 19 mois de
l'élection présidentielle
je vous raconte tout ça alors on
attendait la déclaration des manuels
macron cet après-midi dans une crèche
dans l'essonne à longjumeau
mais c'est finalement sur son compte
instagram que le président de la
république a annoncé la nouvelle plus de
temps pour les futurs papas pour qu'ils
puissent cajoler leur bébé un peu plus
longtemps
nous allons porter le congé paternité à
un mois un mois au sein desquels il y
aura un service obligatoire pour chaque
jeune femme à cette annonce n'a pas
tardé de faire réagir les députés ici à
l'assemblée alors bien sûr tout le monde
trouve que c'est une bonne idée même si
certains n'hésitent pas à y voir une
dépense supplémentaire dont j'ai entendu
parler de 800 millions d'euros à
vérifier tout cas c'est un chiffre qui
circulait savent commence à faire un peu
d'argent et je trouve qu'en ce moment on
a tendance à une distribution assez
généreuse et on ne voit pas trop comment
tout ça se finance il est important que
l'on puisse évidemment le s'occuper de
ses enfants en très bas âge c'est pas
uniquement même si c'est le rôle de la
femme de la maman c'est aussi le rôle du
papa que les deux puissent s'occuper
également de cette arrivée
de l'enfant c'est vraiment quelque chose
de
de formidables avancées formidables
alors en passant de 14 jours à 28 jouant
la france progresse mais elle reste bien
loin très loin derrière d'autres voisins
européens et sur ce sujet là ce sont les
pays du nord qui font la course en tête
en suède par exemple compter 4 180 jours
de congés parentaux à partager entre les
deux parents
au danemark c'est 413 mais ici en france
des députés veulent qu'on aille encore
plus loin
ils ont déposé une proposition de loi
bonjour guillaume chiche
alors vous dans la niche écologique
démocratie à solidarité vous proposer
d'allonger le congé paternité non pas à
un mois comme l'a annoncé emmanuel
macron mais à trois mois pourquoi au nom
d'une logique de l'intérêt de l'enfant
au nom d'une logique égalitaire entre
les femmes et les hommes
je crois qu'il faut allonger le congé
paternité moi je propose de 12 semaines
dont huit semaines obligatoires pour que
tout un chacun puisse s'investir dans sa
famille et auprès des nouveaux nés je
crois que vous êtes jeune papa vous les
auriez pris un vol et deux mois de congé
paternité
j'ai une situation on va dire une
activité qui est celle de député qui a
un petit peu singulière en revanche
avant de devenir député
j'étais un salarié s'il m'avait été
donné l'opportunité pendant deux mois
huit semaines d'être aux côtés de ma
compagne pour l'aider dans des tâches
qui sont difficiles
eh bien oui je l'aurais aurait pris avec
très grand plaisir voilà myriam la
proposition de guillaume chiche sera
débattu dans l'hémicycle le 8 octobre
prochain mais elle a peu de chances
d'aboutir
en revanche l'annoncent d'emmanuel
macron elle sera votée dans le projet de
loi de finances de la sécurité sociale
et devrait rentrer en vigueur au mois de
juillet 2021 ouais après votre congé
paternité je sais pas un bon élève
j'avais pris quelques jours mais j'ai
pas pris mon congé paternité je pensais
ce que je n'étais pas débuté d'ailleurs
j'étais collaborateur parlementaire mais
d'écouter ce que disait guillaume si je
me disais au fond la question ne pas
savoir si on est député ministre ou ou
salariés question c'est que la culture
masculine dont je suis assez imprégnées
sorte de cette logique de parce qu'on
est on serait très occupé on pourrait
pas prendre son congé paternité c'est un
choix il ya des femmes qui font beaucoup
de sacrifices pour prouve pour élever
des enfants et donc il ya quelque chose
je pense que ça c'est jeu personne n'est
parfait donc je donne aucune leçon et
j'ai moi même comment dirais je peux
vrai comme il fallait sans doute il ya
quand même un besoin que nous mêmes nous
réfléchissions et c'est pour ça que
c'est bien dans cette mesure aussi qu'à
une porte d'obligations parce que je
pense que ça permet aux hommes de
réfléchir à leur place et leur rôle
auprès des jeunes le message est bien
passé merci infiniment pour ce débat ali
zeniter une romancière un ministre sur
ce plateau mark leno et un associatif un
militant de terrain
l214 mais l'hérault c'était passionnant
c'est la fin de cette émission
à demain
[Musique]